[Music]
people were chanting conan right now but
a lot of people were also chanting
supreme court decision on health care
there they are right over there
people are electrified by this story
young people are chanting it they're
talking about it
and here's the latest there's talk that
the supreme court may issue their
upcoming decision on health care reform
on live television did you hear this
when they decide it may be on live
television yeah and to boost ratings
each judge will give their decision
after spinning around in their chair to
face the camera
[Applause]
i think the supreme court should do that
all the time on every decision sure that
would get all of us interested again
don't you think
absolutely get ceelo on the court
uh president obama has issued an order
allowing some illegal immigrants to stay
in the united states
yeah mitt romney says he's fine with
this plan at least until his landscaping
is finished
[Applause]
there's this crazy controversy in
michigan several male politicians have
banned a female politician from speaking
on the house floor because she used the
word vagina
yeah it's not that they don't want her
to say it it's that they want her to say
it slower while unbuttoning her blouse
that's true
yesterday microsoft unveiled a new
tablet called surface
yeah microsoft says it shows the name
surface because it's a great place to
put your ipad
[Applause]
hey
get this
yes
i just want to try that out right right
from now on before i joke hey gang get
this
no one else does that it gives them time
to put their hand in your ear
i saw people in the audience go hey
hey gang gather round
that's another one i could do yeah i've
got the skinny gather round gang
these are things i'm trying out every
night just to change it up
maybe doing this
in an interview with oprah kim
kardashian said she fell into a deep
depression because of her divorce
yeah then oprah said she fell into a
deep depression because she was
interviewing kim kardashian
[Applause]
i can't believe you gave me an award for
that job
it's fantastic
put it right there
hey gang
did you hear this adidas adidas is
discontinuing a pair of sneakers that
critics are calling racist racist
sneakers yeah
so today may be your last chance to buy
a pair of air mel gibsons
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
researchers have found that several baby
shampoos listen to this baby shampoos
can cause newborns to test positive for
marijuana
yeah
yeah
so moms think twice before you wash your
baby's hair with pantene's green apple
gunja stank
[Applause]
looks like it's cool
how did they find this out like yeah
that's the bigger question
who's testing babies for marijuana
that baby looks high yeah
that's the part we should be
investigating
here's a kooky story check this out gang
a belgian man has built an exact replica
of luke skywalker's childhood home
yeah
yeah when asked what his wife thinks the
man said wife that's a good one
[Applause]